las autoridades sanitarias de beijing
corre en una carrera contrarreloj contra
los nuevos casos de kobe 19 una tercera
ronda de test masivos está en marcha en
el distrito de chaoyang la idea es
identificar rastrear y aislar para
evitar un confinamiento de toda la
capital como sucedió en shanghai
creo que el gobierno municipal de
beijing no será como el de shanghai
beijing no vivirá un rebrote como el
suyo causado por el relajamiento de la
prevención y el control y
hace un mes las autoridades decretaron
el confinamiento de los más de 25
millones de habitantes de shanghai la
capital económica de china ahora la
mitad ya puede salir de sus casas aunque
muchos no pueden salir de su zona
residencial mientras que la otra mitad
continúa encerrada los nuevos casos
prolongan los confinamientos y en
algunos casos escasean los productos
básicos los vecinos han organizado
protestas a través de las ventanas
pidiendo el suministro de alimentos sin
embargo las autoridades sanitarias
continúan teñidas a la política del
género kobe con el argumento de que los
beneficios a la larga superan los
inconvenientes del corto plazo chivas
freixenet aun si la batalla contra la
epidemia global de kobe 19 es una guerra
una guerra de resistencia una guerra del
pueblo
tenemos que ser conscientes de que la
epidemia el virus es lo que está
perjudicando nuestra economía sectores y
nísida soy jugoso los residentes de
beijing y shanghai no son los únicos
confinados del país de hecho de
distintas formas están limitados los
movimientos de unas 180 millones de
personas este viernes la directiva del
partido comunista reveló sus planes para
reforzar la economía la pandemia y la
guerra en ucrania han puesto presión en
el ejecutivo que enfrenta un año clave
en el que se espera que el presidente de
xi jinping renueve para un inédito
tercer mandato